it's kind of a fluffy move and Gibson is
great in it I really like Gibson he's a
great actor he really is trains get the
gringo also known as how I spent my
summer vacation came out on DirecTV on
May 1st in America and I decide you know
what I like gifts and I'm a fan of gifts
and I'm gonna watch it it's basically
about a career criminal played by Gibson
who gets locked up in this very strange
Mexican prison that's not so much a
prison it's basically just like a
squared off place in which people are
forced to live kind of like a slum but
they have freedom they can walk around
they can even buy drugs and smoke and
beer and you know burgers and stuff
there's restaurants in there it's a very
strange prison any meets this young kid
in there it's actually the kid from the
sitter with Jonah Hill and he had like a
very serious role in this movie he's
just this kid he's like 10 years old he
likes to smoke he has like all these
problems he was raised in this place and
so he's obviously a very hardened child
you know he doesn't have a childhood and
Gibson learns through him how to
interact in this world and the kid
learns through Gibson you know how to be
a little bit more mature and everything
and eventually some stuff happens I
don't want to spoil that basically it's
Gibson to have to fight back against a
whole bunch of the people involved in
this prison Gibson's Martin rigs like
insanity from Lethal Weapon just comes
out and he basically explodes on
everybody I enjoyed this movie I thought
it was a fun watch it was a movie that I
was always interested in I enjoyed
seeing where the characters were going
to go Gibson just has this really
hardened quality now not just in his
face but in his voice is a very gravelly
voice and it works for his character
because he creates this really realistic
edgy demeanor about him and you really
buy him in that location you buy him as
a person they can go into a place like
that and work his way around people and
you know make friends with the right
people understand how things work and
get away with doing certain things that
other people can't do you really buy
that about his character but it's also
the relationship between him and the boy
that I liked and we've seen that a lot
you know you take someone who's really
hardened possibly a killer like
Terminator and John Carter in Terminator
2 give them a relationship you humanize
the character it's been done before but
I like when they do that if it works
well and the kid isn't annoying and I
like the kid in this movie I thought he
did a pretty good job the movie
definitely has issues and I think my
biggest issue with the movie is just
it's not terribly remarkable in any way
it's just a fun watch for me there
wasn't really anything
the film's direction or script that blew
my mind or surprised me or wow that's
just so awesome it's just a fun time I
like the action of the movie Martin
Riggs is coming out you know the lethal
weapon side of him that crazy side like
this is really crazy scene in the movie
where I just felt like an adrenaline
rush from Gibson he like bursts out in
this alley he looks down he sees his
enemy way off in the distance he just
like bolts for him like as fast as he
possibly can his eyes are just like
inflamed and everything I was like
Gibson man you are insane and this
really works for this movie he has a
really great way of bringing an
intensity that other actors can't bring
to an action scene and he does that a
lot here but like I said there really
isn't anything very remarkable about
this movie it's just one of those movies
where you probably not watch I'd be like
yeah that was fine but I enjoyed that
but you'll probably never watch it again
but you won't hate yourself for watching
it and Gibson is really great in the
movie he's really the high point so I'm
gonna give dip the gringo a b-minus
so let me know what's your favorite Mel
Gibson movie mine's like Braveheart
Lethal Weapon signs you know I just
really like him he's a great actor and
until next time guys if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes